[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous alors on va voyager
ensemble durant les prochaines minutes
mais avant cela je vais je vais
commencer par vous poser une question
d'ailleurs c'est une question que vous
avez déjà entendu des dizaines et des
dizaines de fois
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire dans la
vie
pour celles et ceux qui arrivent à
formuler une réponse ce serait
intéressant de regarder si c'est la même
chose que les années passées
autrement dit
suivez toujours
le bon cap
personnellement moi je n'ai jamais su
je voulais faire de ma vie est parfois
ça m'agace et je n'ai jamais eu de rêve
particulier et donc de vision claire du
futur que je voulais avoir
sion des activités extra scolaires qui
me donnaient du plaisir et qui me
construisait et pour moi ces activités
définissez ma personne dans sa
complexité
il
un métier aucun ne me donnait
l'impression de me corresponde
parfaitement simple
moi même à chaque fois pour entrer dans
la case
et c'est un peu étonnant d'ailleurs non
sens
à voir précisément ce que l'on veut eh
bien parfois on est quand même amené à
faire des études longues et il ya trois
ans j'ai fini attention diplômés
ingénieurs en conception mécanique
ingénieur en conception mécanique cinq
ans d'études dans les sciences po ce bac
sans savoir ce que je voulais
c'est un peu paradoxal quand même non
ça parce que j'ai aimé apprendre je l'aï
jamais apprendre les sciences et j'avais
le temps la vie étudiante était chouette
mais je ne savais pas quel est mon
métier
d'ailleurs je l' ai compris qu après qu
il ait compris
mon stage de fin d'études je m'en
souviens bien j'étais assis à mon bureau
et je venais de recevoir des
instructions de la part de son supérieur
il me demandait comme ça de concevoir un
système mécanique c'était pas prévu et
ça me prend du temps j'étais avachi est
déprimée parce que je n'avais qu'une
hâte celle de rentrer chez moi pour
faire ce que j'aime et pratiquer la
musique
fille
et je devais me résigner
soir serait encore un soir où je ne
rentrerais que pour dîner et dormir
mon métier je le voyais enfin c'est
celui que j'avais étudié et c'était
celui que j'allais faire toute ma vie
g
surpris de l'apprendre alors que ça
faisait cinq ans que j'étais censé me
préparer
à ce moment précis j'ai compris que je
fasse
sur fallait que je stoppe je voulais
faire un bilan de ma vie et redéfinir la
direction qu'elle allait prendre
c'est vrai que lens
dans la vie active ou même étudiant on
n'arrive pas à penser calmement ya
toujours quelque chose à faire un
problème à résoudre comment peut-on
savoir précisément ce que l'on veut
un pas pour ces quatre mamans
c'est là que j'ai compris je voulais pas
de voix
si vous voulez une retraite
le voyage de le faire intérieurement là
bas
j'ai pensé à elle
allah
symbole emblématique
de la méditation et gt gt surpris qu'on
pouvait aller vivre dans un monastère
bouddhiste là-bas pour pas grand chose
en fait il suffit de simplement
participer à la communauté
alors j'ai sauté
l'occasion
et une fois dans l'avion je partais
enfin j'ai quitté la france pour 3 mois
3 mois de calme
entrée
en arrivant là bas on est émerveillé par
toute cette beauté imaginez vous à moins
acheter un grand comme ça avec une
centaine d'enfants dedans et et plus
d'une trentaine d'adultes et lorsqu'on
n'arrive lorsqu'on franchit les portes
de ce monastère
on laisse de côté tous les problèmes du
quotidien
et quand je dis tous les problèmes c'est
vraiment tous les problèmes plus besoin
de travailler plus besoin de réviser
plus besoin de répondre aux mails même
plus besoin de savoir quoi acheter à
manger
il fallait simplement vivre au rythme
des moines
aussant leurs cloches
on m'a donné un lit à manger et au final
c'était simple ça me suffisait
et au bout de quelques semaines j'ai
j'ai commencé à être
photo et à témoigner de ce que je vivais
chaque
tin nous nous faisions réveillé vers
5h30 par un moine fou qui tapait sur un
gong dans la cour du monastère et nous
n'avions que 15 minutes pour rejoindre
le temple centrale et nous asseoir
une fois sur notre petit coussin s'en
suivait ensuite une heure de chant de
mantra durant une cérémonie qui
s'appelle la poudre
et lorsque nous
fini je voyais les moines qui sortait en
poussant les rideaux du temple et
envoyer le soleil qui commençait à
rentrer dedans c'était magnifique
chaque jour nous mangeons dehors assis
par terre
chose adou trois légumes prêts
chanter que les groupes commencent et a
changé
on est davantage le temps j'étais plus
présents dans ce que je faisais en fait
j'avais rien qui me ap l'esprit comme la
télévision et la publicité
il avait juste des enfants
2 - qui mangeait et qui parfois voulais
jouer pour me parler
d'ailleurs avec eux en trois mois
inconnu à professeur d'anglais plutôt
cool et puis même parfois ami et
confident
je me rappelle que j'ai été témoin de
moments de vie magnifique comme celui là
où environ une fois par mois
les moines se rase le crâne entre eux
pour eux c'est un signe de sobriété de
renoncement la société de consommation
et du paraître et pour d'autres
prétexte pour s'amuser d'ailleurs dans
les deux lui c'est une grosse capeline
en cours il n'était pas très sympa et
parfois il m'arrive et sortir du
monastère et d'aller marcher dans la
campagne et j'en ai découvert un autre
perché en haut d'une montagne il était
magnifique aussi et j'ai eu de la chance
parce qu'en y allant ce jour là c'est
aussi un jour de repos pour les enfants
et j'en ai croisé un petit groupe qui
s'amusait avec des feuilles en papier on
a construit des airbus a380 forcément et
les avons lancé du haut du petit muret
et au bout de quelques semaines je
sentais que que l'euphorie commencé à
redescendre j'ai découvert l'ennui
c'est un sentiment hostile pour l'homme
qu'il a appris à déjouer avec énormément
de stratagèmes le plus connu vous le
connaissez bien c'est votre smartphone
mettez de côté quelques minutes et
l'ennui revient à chaque fois
je me rappelle que je passais des heures
dans ma chambre allongé sur mon lit dans
le silence
j'expérimente l ennui je regardais le
plafond et avait rien à regarder
et pourtant et pourtant je le regardais
avec attention
au bout d'un moment je me découvrais
j'ai vu comme ça qu'il ya plein de
choses qui se passent en moi
plein de choses qui bougent on entend
aussi plein de choses dans le silence
vers j'avais des acouphènes
chercher sur internet j'ai compris qu'en
fait tout le monde en avait c'est
simplement qu'on ne prend pas conscience
qu'ils sont là parce qu'on ne les écoute
pas vous
phase avec moi-même chanter que je
pouvais redéfinir la direction calais
prendre ma vie et j'avais le courage
de me reposer la fameuse question du
début
à m
tous
qu'est ce que tu veux vraiment faire de
ta vie
une possibilité d' échouer
se poser cette question sa demande bout
et pendant pour moi il a fallu casser
toutes les barrières mentales que
j'avais levé et kim définissez en huit
ans je mettais progressivement fait à
l'idée que j'allais devenir ingénieur
ces barrières et qu'on se demande
vraiment mais vraiment quel métier en
vue
commence enfin à réfléchir
je puis dans le prisme de ses études on
va plus loin on réfléchit comme un
enfant qui n'a pas été formaté par son
environnement
réfléchis commun
enfants à qui on n'a jamais dit tu es
bon dans ça m'était manger là dedans
et au bout d'un moment je sentais que
j'arrivais à formuler une réponse
phrase
vivre
en donnant toujours suffisamment de
temps au développement de ce qui me
passionne
je souhaite vivre en donnant toujours
suffisamment de temps au développement
de ce qui me passionne j'ai pas parlé de
photographies parce que je suis pas dupe
peut-être qu'un jour ça allait me lasser
mais je voulais quand même à donner le
temps d'essayer
vous savez c'est ce petit temps qui vous
permet parfois de passer des amateurs et
professionnels
et à la fin il fallait bien que je
rentre
que j'économise parce que la vraie vie
allait continuer d'avancer à une vitesse
folle
je venais de signer pour un cdi en tant
qu'ingénieur
mais c'était pas grave parce que j'avais
enfin mon but j'avais mon j'avais mon
pourquoi j'avais mon moteur
et je savais que pour pouvoir avoir la
totale liberté d'entreprendre et
mouvements je devais m'émanciper du
salariat mais avant cela fallait que
j'apprenne et sa durée comme ça un an et
demi un an et demi de métro boulot dodo
et je peux vous jurer quand on a fait
trois mois dans un monastère
découvrez le métro parisien c'est pas
sympa et au bout d'un moment
commence à déprimer
quand je regardais autour de moi tout le
monde était plutôt satisfait de son
travail
qui était le mien je me disais quoi et
congés payés et les rtt la sécurité
d'emploi c'est quand même pas mal
et puis chanter aussi la pression
sociale qui pesé vous savez en comparant
des métiers dits valorisant comme
l'ingénierie
à d'autres comme la photographie
attaquants même pas fait tout ça pour
rien bon ça va pas là ok mais t'inquiète
pas c'est y aurait matière à mieux
demain aller
et mon préféré vous le connaissez cinq
ans d'études pour être ingénieur et
finir photographe les jeunes formatrice
entendu enfin moi je leur ai entendu au
début ça me touchait et après ça me
passer au dessus
et un jour je
sentez prêt je suis parti et cela fait
maintenant plus d'un an que je suis
photographe que je suis à mon compte que
je travaille pour moi et j'ai pu gagner
correctement ma vie cette année
développer de nouvelles compétences dans
le web dans l'infographie dans
l'ingénierie
et quand j'ai du temps je pars je me
on donne dans des pays là par exemple
c'était au kirghizstan alors le cas à
distance et impayés impossible à
prononcer personnes celles écrire j'ai
découvert la culture nomade et surtout
l'hospitalité on nous a accueillis on
nous donnait à manger à boire il avait
rien
parfois c'est pas c'est pas dans des
pays isolés c'est dans des villes où je
vais comme là
d'où j'ai croisé une femme en âge
sourire parce que parfois quand je suis
avec mon sac à dos que je suis bien
l'appareil photo autour du cou
je me sens en bon endroit au bon moment
je me sens dans ce petit moment
singulier où je me dis ouah cure
c'est là où il faut que ce soit
enfin compris et eu la preuve qu il
science qu'il faut cultiver ses
créativité et ne jamais cessé
d'apprendre
j'ai compris que tout ce que je faisais
8 ans avait une cohérence
mais il a fallu huit ans pour m'en
apercevoir huit ans pour comprendre que
même l'ingénierie mad aujourd'hui dans
mon métier de photographe
en fait
suffisamment un qu'on arrive avant le
tableau en entier
je suis intimement persuadé que nous
aimons tous des choses en dehors de
notre activité principale est qu'il est
primordial d'entretenir sa curiosité
si l'on s'abandonne suffisant
m
jour après jour de cultiver cette petite
flamme de la curiosité de la passion
alors petit à petit
man
se retourne et hong kong
enfin la cohérence de nos actions
il ne restera
dans ce fameux pilote automatique pour
amorcer un changement
et maintenant j'ai envie de vous reposer
une question ce soir
dir
est ce que vous voulez vraiment faire de
votre vie si vous n'avez aucune
possibilité d' échouer
[Applaudissements]